if there's one thing tesla fans have
always complained about regarding their
company it has to be their deadlines the
company seemed to have developed a habit
of releasing cool fan art huge specs and
footage maybe even a prototype and then
poof the car would be gone and the
people would be left waiting however
just last month the company held an
employee meeting and in that meeting we
received confirmation of a bunch of new
projects and not just that all of them
are pointing toward one special thing
the fact that 2023 will be the year of
tesla so if you're interested in finding
out more about this keynote their new
announcements what exactly we can expect
from these announcements and where the
company is headed in general tune in
because we have a whole load of news for
you now with that out of the way let's
jump right in background if you go a
decade back and try to find out about
tesla from your average layman you will
get nothing but a blank stare or random
tidbits about the old scientist however
in just a short period of time the
company has gone from a low-volume
gimmick company to a full-on trendsetter
and with multiple factories and four
cars selling out before a shipment is
even delivered on a regular basis the
company doesn't seem to want to stop
anytime soon and the very latest meeting
that the company held regarding their
direction is just the confirmation we
needed and not just that while other
press conferences and presentations have
a habit of making stuff look like more
than what it actually is this meeting is
a little different from others since
instead of it being a press conference
it's actually an employee conference
what that means is that the stuff set in
it is actually done so in a serious mood
and has a lot more credibility now with
the context established let's take a
look at the news which is mostly in the
form of reports and tweets from inside
the conference which basically gives us
a word-by-word recreation of what went
on and although there is a ton to unpack
there are three announcements that are
of special interest to us those being
the not one not two but three cars that
tesla wants to unveil in 2023 and with a
lot happening in the world tesla's new
self-driving software new factories
bigger sales numbers and it is just
generally a prime time to be the biggest
ev manufacturer in the world and so it
is not surprising that the company plans
to ride the high wave onto victory so
with that cleared up here's the first
main car one cyber truck now i hear all
of your cries of revulsion and yes the
cyber truck is kind of old news now but
technically speaking we still don't know
much about the actual truck in real life
and with the now iconic presentation
fail it was obvious that the car was
still at that point very much a
prototype and the actual thing coming
out is not going to be small news and
well quite appropriately we do have some
actual juicy news on that see the
biggest thing that separates the cyber
truck from the other tesla cars is the
body which unlike aluminum for the
others is made up of steel in the truck
allowing more strength and general
toughness and because of that the
company had to wait a while to release
it since they just don't have enough
steel but along came spacex with their
own need of a steel factory for their
starship rocket and you have elon
pooling in money to make a steel plant
and that's great news for tesla as well
as spacex because that basically means
greater efficiency in building shipping
and all that good stuff and apart from
the steel factory itself we also have
the gigafactory in texas which is also
starting to come into its own and why is
that relevant you ask well it's because
it's the place the truck will actually
be made and with the steel plant
expected to start working in late 2021
and cyber truck to start production by
2022 as listed by its official site it's
pretty much confirmed that you will
start to see the iconic if neo had a
truck as said by elon on the streets 2.
tesla model 2. now here's the thing elon
musk and by extension tesla has for
quite some time had only one main goal
to make ev's the main source of
transportation and to do that they've
been gunning to release a small form
factor low-cost vehicle that'll be their
proper entry into their desired market
and it's just a simple fact that no
matter how great your high-end sales are
the actual cars that sell are the
corollas and the ford focuses of the
world and that's exactly what the
company wants to make with the model 2.
if you want to know more about this car
we made a video about it i let you watch
it on the channel so before we get into
more detail though did you know that the
model 2 is not the car's official name
many people think that since the model 3
already exists it makes sense for them
to make a model 2. however the model 3
name was accidental the reason being
that elon wanted the name model 3 for
his grand scheme of model s model e
model x and model y however that name
was already copyrighted by ford so he
had to go by the name of model 3. anyway
weird tangent aside although the car is
the ultimate goal and with the 4680
battery and the gigashanghai factory
underway there are decent chances of it
happening not just yet because it is
still very much in development but just
how far is this something that varies
from person to person another good
indicator besides the technology on the
manufacturing is the image revealed in
the form of an official sketch that
allegedly is of the upcoming car as the
sketch shows the car belongs to the
newer model 3 and model y style with
soft headlights and a very futuristic
look and that conveniently brings us to
the last important part regarding this
car self-driving see tesla is not just
concerned about people driving their
cars in fact in the long term they want
no one to drive their cars because they
want all their cars to be fully
self-driving and well as it turns out
the single biggest expected feature of
this car will actually be the lack of
features because in the aforementioned
conference according to elon himself the
car may actually feature the first big
attempt by tesla to make a completely
autonomous vehicle you see although
there were plans to make a model y with
no steering wheel they just didn't come
to fruition but with the version 10.1 of
tesla's autopilot system on the way
along with an extensive beta program i
don't think it's a stretch to say that
the first instance of a completely
autonomous car might be the model 2. for
god's sake we have even had an image of
one such car all the way back how
exciting is that and the absolute icing
on the cake has got to be this quote
that was taken right out of elon's
address to the employees regarding the
future of the company in the model 2.
the ceo plainly asked do we want to have
this car come with a steering wheel and
pedals and so that's the model 2 tesla's
final big nail in the coffin of all
sorts of old cars and the exact details
like the year of release remain a little
smudged as tesla is known for being
secretive about any concrete plans they
have i personally believe that the car
is somewhere in the late development
cycle and if all goes to plan you can
expect to see it as soon as 2023 so
let's keep our fingers crossed 3.
robovan first a truck called cybertruck
and now a robo van and i love this
company still geekiness aside the robo
van is one of the more elusive of
tesla's projects however that does not
mean that it is not a likely contender
for the year 2023 you see there is a
long time running rumor among tesla fans
about elon and his company developing
large-scale public transportation as its
behind the scenes project and while
there have been numerous indicators of
that in the past with musk confirming
all the way back that a tesla van was
extremely likely to happen although he
didn't specify one exactly however there
are two things that make us think that
it's coming namely what we hear at the
conference and secondly the new
self-driving tech as for the latter the
conference has probably been the biggest
revelation and the fact that not only do
they plan to make it but they also
intend to have it be specialized for
people with disabilities this ties
perfectly into the next point which is
that tesla will most probably not make
their van drivable instead it will act
as a perfectly autonomous vehicle that
will take up duties of public
transportation all over the country from
giving easy rides to the elderly and
children to just being a good way to
commute this van will be the first foray
of the company into public vehicles
still despite all of that a lot remains
to be said and we'll be sure to give you
news of any updates as soon as we get
them well guys that was a very brief
summary of what tesla has been up to all
this time thank you so much for watching
and i hope you enjoyed the video and if
you did please leave a like and i'll see
you next time